hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapter 4 is
working to latarian ISM John Stuart Mill
is trying to make a case for
utilitarianism being able to bring in to
to address the criticisms lagging by
those who want to say that pleasure and
pain pleasure lack of pain or happiness
cannot be the human beings ultimate atom
or goal there are other things that we
find equally valuable yeah you talked
about a number of different things but
one of the great life is that he has to
do that he has to deal with is this
notion of virtue and this is a term that
was used quite a lot in his own time we
don't use it as much these things but
you can substitute in place of virtue
you could say Karen meaning good
character meaning having certain good
character traits virtues are good traits
of character they're not just things you
do once a while they are typical of the
virtuous
generosity example persons not generous
if they do one generous action they're
generous if they do gender generous
actions as an expression of the kind of
person of the artist a bunch of second
nature is there don't you their default
likewise a person can be vicious a
person who's greedy you can count on
them to act a greedy way in all across
different situations a person can be
saying lacks a good work ethic who's
lazy cuts corners will cut corners
whether they're working on a task
whether they're you know practically
food whether they are engaging in
counseling whether they're spending time
with their kids or their aging parents
they will they will cut corners that's
part of their character so there were a
lot of people who are saying that that
pleasure is not the fundamental good
that virtue virtuous activity is or the
possession of bridges Aristotle's a
great example of this so middle has to
try to make a case for how many Tillet
arianism can bring virtue into its own
scope let's start by thinking about this
utilitarianism makes happiness the end
the goal hermes is the end of we often
talk in terms of the goals desired
outcomes yeah what is happiness it's
pleasure or a lack of the pain overall
in one's life again the way that he says
people tend to look at this is that all
those things are just merely means so
whatever Goods we have over here take
money power opportunity hard work career
friends houses you know property cars
all these sorts of things are
are merely goods education and what
makes them good is that they produce a
greater balance of pleasure over pain
which is what we really want we're not
really that interested in the goods
we're interested in the pleasure that
they provide us or the pain that they
take away yeah mill says if that was
really the case then we'd have some
problems as utilitarians he points out
when it comes to virtue says it's
palpable that human beings not only
desire happiness but they desire the
things which in common language are
decidedly distinguished from happiness
they desire for example virtue and the
absence of us well think about this
rivet we'll go back to the text there is
within at least many of us a desire to
at least be able to think of ourselves
as having good character traits for does
not have a bad character case going
beyond that in some of us there is a
genuine desire to actually have good
character it's not just to think of
ourselves that way or to appear to
others that way but to actually be just
courageous generous to be that kind of
person to be a good person fulsome to be
a noble person to be a stand-up guy we
could talk about this although you're
wet there are some cultural variants and
exactly how these are thinking thought
about and even within cultures there's
arguments about exactly which character
traits are more important they should
look like we're going to put that aside
for the moment
likewise when somebody finds out that
they have bad character traits they they
often don't want to think of themselves
as having those you know procrastination
for example which is often an expression
of perfectionism is something that a
person will tell themselves is not
really that big a deal or is something
they only do once in a while and really
it's become rooted
and it would take a lot of work to get
rid of it and you know why do we live
with ourselves about these things in
part because we don't want to think of
ourselves as vicious you know if I have
a bad temper problem I don't want to
think of myself as having a genuinely
vicious disposition with respect to
anger I want to think of myself it's
just once in a while going off the
handle too far so Noah's right people do
in fact desire virtue in the absence of
lights and they they desire this no less
really he says then they desire pleasure
in the absence of pain the desire of
virtues not as universal but it is
that's authentic he says a fact as the
desired happiness so it looks dead like
we have to say there are other rival
ends rival goals and one of these would
be virtue is this really the case so he
says does the utilitarian documen I that
people desire virtue or maintain that
virtue is not a thing to be desired the
very reverse it maintains not only that
virtue is to be desired but it is to be
desired
this interestedly so but that rules out
is making race love this stuff here
making virtue into a mere means for our
happiness now how would that take place
well you know if you act in certain ways
so as in social approval to weight
encourage punishment then your virtuous
disposition would merely be the means
and pleasure and not having pain and you
might even say to yourself you know I
don't really feel like being a generous
person or being honest or being
courageous but it would be better for me
overall you know I think about this
rationally prudentially I look at the
long term I probably have a better life
which would include more pleasure was
pain yeah if I were to cultivate in
myself these virtues and if I were to
embrace from my character sole
personality how people put vices that
would be an instrumental way of looking
at virtue virtue is not a good itself
that virtue is merely a means to the end
of happiness to disinterestedly indoors
virtue is to say that virtue is in fact
a good that is an end something that is
desired for its own sake and desirable
for its own sake so he says utilitarians
can get behind this how says well
utilitarians place virtue at the very
head of things which are good as means
to the ultimate end like this but they
also recognize as a psychological fact
the possibility of it being to the
individual of good in itself without
looking to any and Beyond and hold that
the mind is not in the right state not
on a state conformable to utility not on
the state most conducive to the general
happiness unless it really does love
virtue in this manner so what this means
is that
actually becomes bigger we thought
virtue is not only the means to
happiness
virtue is also a component of happiness
and not just virtue for outward
appearance not just virtue as like
something you can take a pill of dude
but virtually understood by the
individual as something that is good for
them good in itself something they can
entirely endorse and say this needs to
be part of who I am
so Mill says this works for a lot of
other things he says the ingredients of
happiness are very various and each of
them is desirable in itself not merely
when considered is swelling and
aggregate the principle of utility does
not mean that I mean given pleasure as
music for instance or any give an
exemption from pain as for example
health is to be looked at as merely a
means to a collective something term
happiness and desired I'm going to come
they are desired and desirable in and
for themselves
besides being means they are part of so
the same thing holds for virtue now this
raises some questions how do we get
there how do we arrive at such a state
where we would come to identify virtue
not only as a means you know I'm
something Prudential but as a part a
component of the genuinely happy life
this is something that would appear to
be a bit puzzle so middle says is let's
think about other goods think about
money crazy why do you want money pretty
much all of us do what is it about money
that actually makes it desirable for you
so he says it's association association
with with the thing that means to so you
have some money you're able to buy some
things
what does that give you that gives me
pleasure or you could use the money to
take to you know take care of situations
in your closet your pain you take away
that pain you now have an association of
good feelings or you know the removal of
bad feelings with money and the more
that you do it the more of these
feelings you have the more consolidated
the more intense they become they have
sort of fused together and it becomes
part of the effective let's call it the
affective halo or signature of that good
he says the same thing could be said
about the majority of the great objects
of human life power for example or fame
except that to each of these there's a
certain amount of immediate pleasure in
next we like to feel empowered
we like the feeling of girls but why did
we come to value these as part of
happiness we do that because of the good
associations with originally with blood
hair removal of pain they come about and
eventually even if these things aren't
causing us pain and pleasure directly we
still have that good Association we come
see them as ends on their own so he says
in these sorts of cases that means that
become a part of the end and a more
important part of it than any of the
things that they're means to so power
can become the end for some people thing
can become video ad for some people
really you could go if you look at the
traditional list of all the possible
goods that are candidates for happiness
and you can come up with some sort of
psychological explanation for you know
about how a individual would come to
value that good so so high security for
example one's job a relationship stamp
collecting
and whatever you like now what about
virtue
so it says virtue
according to utilitarian conception fits
this kind of description originally we
didn't design it we didn't desire these
character traits why did we come to
desire we associated them to pleasure
probably because doing these sorts of
things brought about good situations for
us in which things worked out I'll think
about courage for example not only is
that something that tends to be higher
than people but also it helps you get
things done helps you get things
accomplished so you come to associated
with the good feelings that come about
from whatever it is it that got
accomplished yeah generosity you know
other people will praise it and liking
them and talk you know about you is a
good person and you like that and so
then you come to associate generosity
it's often the pleasure that we get from
that and then after a while you lose
sight of this association you begin to
like it says through the accessibility
Association may be formed and maybe felt
a bit of itself and desires with its
great intensity as an inner good and
virtue of eventually says those who
desire virtue for its own sake desire
and either because the consciousness of
it is a pleasure or because the
consciousness of being with atoms of the
pain gets so closely tied in that our
pleasures and the pains that if we go
far enough with it we actually feel a
sense of pain and lacking in virtue or
to discovering vice with themselves or
another people let's say a breath and
over time we forget about all this
association of thinking place what you
know subconsciously
thing he had we come to see virtue then
as something that is an integral
component of happiness and it becomes
very difficult for us to conceive of the
happy life without virtue or the vicious
life as being a happy life
that's how mill tries to incorporate
what he thinks is right about virtue
ethics into utilitarianism it's an
interesting argument try to show that
utilitarianism can actually cover all
these other things yeah it could be used
to talk about other goods but he's
focusing primarily the good of virtue